To put trees back or to be a part of the force of people putting trees back into this land,...
...broadleaf trees, hardwood forests...
...spills over a rich abundance, which isn't related to money...
...or material possessions.
To be amongst forests,...
...particularly at this stage, a young forest is also very enlivening.
I think what's new about The Local Project is that if it's...
...firmly rooted into the community instead of just with the efforts of one individual,...
...then there's a possibility that the forest will be allowed to grow on through the generations.
And that the timber then coming from those forests,...
...there will be a continual supply built up over the years, which is actually what the industry needs,...
...and that's what The Local Project was about,...
...to make a beginning in that direction.
That's all we can do in this lifetime.